are you they have this me everybody  wonders how they look for other people  this is how I look to a soundman I bring  this up too cause i or friendly thin  green line I'm about to present the  Academy Award for the best achievement  in sound now you want to see what a  laugh looks like you want to see what a  smile looks like you want to see that an  envelope looks like for the best  achievement in sound the nominees are  the sound departments of Warner Brothers  seven arts for bullet and for Finian's  Rainbow Columbia Pictures for funny girl  Shepperton studios for Oliver and 20th  Century Fox for star and the winner is  Shepperton studios for Olive Oyl  on behalf of shepherds in studios sound  Department I accept this award Ingrid